my next guest who's sitting to my right
nominated for a Grammy twice over an
Emmy and now her new show under a rock
would TIG Notaro that's streaming right
now on Funny or Die the latest guest was
me we figured let's have taken a taro on
my show the only difference is I know
who you are as you sat down in the seat
tic good to see you
good to see you so the construction to
see you and know who you are exactly and
do you know who I am right now
right now yes okay cuz the concept of
under Iraq with TIG Notaro is that to
say you have a blind spot for pop
culture and facial recognition is an
affront to the word blind and spot
correct well I don't have facial
recognition issues you don't know I mean
even though you did tell me I met you
one time before yes we had Jeff Garlin
on the show last week you did a stand-up
special with Jeff yeah Largo here in Los
Angeles no it was a special it's
probably just a show yes I felt it was
special and and then I met you
afterwards it's perfect right it was
yeah it was brief yeah but I remembered
it yeah that's okay that you didn't but
you don't recall people you don't know
you a lot of pop culture I follow music
I followed documentaries and the news
right but yeah TV and film I catch
things here and there and of course I
work in entertainment I'm a stand-up
comedian right I do some acting but it's
typically if I've worked as somebody on
a project or I met him socially but yeah
I miss a lot it's shocking so then the
concept that I imagined was pitched to
you is I pitched it who did yeah I came
up with it which is like hey I just
don't know a whole bunch of people right
yeah I thought it'd be funny to do a
talk show where I am face to face with
celebrities and try and figure out who
they are and I say Anne Hathaway I mean
you did not know who Anne Hathaway was
at all I know the name and I had met her
but um
when I ran into her again I I didn't
recognize her and she looked vaguely
familiar okay and I thought I had just
maybe hung out with her a Star Trek wrap
party because I am on Star Trek and I
had just left the wrap party and she
said no I'm Anne Hathaway I met you at
the Beck concert and then when I told my
wife when I went home from Toronto she
said how is it that she's trying to jog
your memory of her from a Beck concert
right and not saying no it's me Anne
Hathaway from Anne Hathaway didn't jog
your memory you know I mean she just
mentioned the Beck concert and I and I
and I know I didn't know I didn't
remember her from the back console other
guest Lena Headey does that mean you
didn't watch Game of Thrones I did not
watch Game of Thrones No so when these
folks come out and sit down by the way
the way you introduce guests fantastic
well can you walk people through how you
introduce your guests on your show yeah
folks might be wondering in TIG Notaro
here under a rock with TIG Notaro
fantastic very popular show streaming on
Funny or Die how you can be a host of a
talk show with the guests you having no
idea who they are and they're presented
to you how can you possibly go through
that as a construct as a host you how do
you introduce folks for those who may
not know how do I bring them out on
stage I say please welcome this person
Chris I'm telling you man it's really
weird as a guest because it as a guest
they tell you okay
don't you're not allowed to come out
until Tigs ready okay all right which is
makes sense you turn around yeah I don't
see anyone right and then you sneak onto
the set behind a curtain and then they
open the curtain up when you say the
words this purse please welcome this
person it's the big time rich
man it is so damn funny it really really
is we were so fun you're so fun I truly
was just like who is this person what
does he do I mean I started to kind of
feel like maybe you were a talk-show
host is that right well cuz you kept
saying that you control conversations
and your voice inflection right there's
certain things after hosting this show
that I've started to kind of you know a
little bit I mean not always
okay not always right but but you know
it's funny as you came out of our green
room you know our our hallway is lined
with photographs of guests who have been
here yeah we put you know famous faces
up on the wall you didn't seem to
recognize a handful of them yeah it's
not that if someone's famous I
absolutely won't know who they are right
there's just a large chunk of people
that astound everyone that I don't I
don't know well it's funny what we could
do is have you walk through the hallway
and there could be future guests for
your show when you pull a rock and not
know who they are yeah they can be going
on but like say when Michael Douglas is
on the wall and you stopped you go
Douglas right I'm like yeah so yeah he's
out I couldn't remember his first name
but I knew it was Douglas I knew there's
a Douglas in there I knew Jane Lynch yes
you did very good so I saw Melissa
Etheridge cliff like what is this a gay
show I was like she was on last week
because that's the Kansas City Chiefs
are you a sports fan whatsoever at all I
mean I grew up playing soccer in
Mississippi right disorder you're from I
was Mississippi and Texas
my brother has he's been a sports radio
host for a decade okay because you told
me after we shot the show that your
brother would be freaking out that you
had no idea yeah he just was on right
yeah and still can't it's his whole
world it's his whole world but I'd my
wife follows yeah football some
basketball but it's she and her father
and her brother and our two three year
old boys watch
but my wife doesn't look like she would
follow football everyone assumes I'm the
one with the short hair that would
follow the football but not well just by
saying follow the football that belies a
certain knowledge yeah you know so
here's what we're gonna do tick because
I had such a blast on your show and now
that you're on on mine I would like to
have a little bit of a similar construct
okay because I know who you are
and now you know who I am and maybe we
could also send you out into the
universe with a little bit more sports
knowledge in a way thank you I love them
we have come up with a handful of sports
terminology and you could give your best
guess what you think it means
and then we'll reveal it to you and you
can use this words in lexicon if you're
ever in needing any stuff like that is
it gonna be stuff like goalpost or clean
no they're not back that it's actual
like sports terminology right that you
may or may not have heard of do we have
music for this mic Delta give me some
music right here under a rock with TIG
Notaro on on Funny or Die can stream it
right now well that's NFL Films music
you're giving right there very good some
of these aren't all football though and
if you want it could be like dispelling
me you could ask me like what's the
sport or use it in the term of a form of
a sentence however you wish here we go
special teams what do you think that
means special teams people that are
teams that are going to championship
okay that's an interesting way it's a
Ferdie what would you describe you don't
even know is a phase phase of a certain
personnel of a football yes yeah they're
only there's offense and defense and
then all the other stuff is specialty
yeah those who kick hunt in football are
the special teams so if you're ever
there and you've watched somebody kicked
and feel go you just certain people and
go they got some good special teams okay
specialty there you go very good a pick
six pick six yeah never heard that one
before
rich what do you think pick six yeah
what do you think that might mean it's
from football it's from football pick
six six yards I like it when somebody
intercepts a football and returns it for
a touchdown they get six points so
somebody gets a pick six hmm
yeah still draws a blank yeah okay I
know the words I've heard these words
okay just not in the order that you're
presenting them all right here's another
one load management load management hmm
is it when they tackle each other and
there's too much of a load basketball
it's a basketball term my answer is now
I would love to get your comedic take on
this load management is the term that
the NBA is currently using for resting
players the players have no injury you
know what I have heard that because
somebody was talking about recently how
if you buy expensive tickets to a game
and you're wanting to see the stars yes
then they feel like it's unfair yes
especially because the player is I was
somebody telling me that because it is a
significant center that knows me well
wouldn't be like oh let me run this by
to let me see what things have load
management see now this is this thing as
well is that load management is the
official term they're calling it when a
player is rested without injury it's
load management maybe I heard it on a
radio show I think I did I just love the
term it just sounds so official for
something that is it it's a new term yes
right what about tomatoes share the last
couple seasons yes we're coming up on
the two year anniversary special load
management roast with Jeffrey Ross load
management I've got a couple more for
you at hat trick hat trick have you
heard hat trick before rich of course
not no no
hat trick would be baseball no it is all
well I mean it could I mean trick is
what you are you when you score three
times if you have three goals or three
of anything soccer and hockey usually
it's called a hat-trick why why it's
called a hat-trick I have nice baseball
players taking their hat off and
flipping it and then having it land on
their head which I guess is very later
we should start doing I should start
calling them I've just been told that
they used to pass around a hat for
players because they didn't get paid
when they have such an accomplishment
it's called a hat trick well so if you
had three great shows in a row
hat trick done last one for you right
here I sing the kicker isolytic that
means is it in football yes and is it
when they run towards the kicker oh so
close so close because they do that when
the punter that's running rushing the
kicker yeah I've seen that happen icing
the kicker
ignore him yes why would you ignore him
no I mean well cuz they're kickers stop
it don't don't feed her head with awful
things like that no icing the kicker is
when there's a big kick in the game is
it celebratory it is not the kicker is
making a big visit the opposing team
calls a timeout to make him think about
it longer and it's kind of putting him
on ice you're icing the kicker oh okay
yeah icing the kicker could also be
putting your final drink on the rocks I
like it
it's the kicker of the love the end of
the night you know we're gonna ice the
kicker I think it's very good but now I
think you can go and talk about well
they normally have a very good special
teams but they're trying to ice the
kicker and that might be a problem rich
I hate to take the conversation away
from sports but why when I got here
today was there not a casserole for me
[Laughter]
yeah no it would have been an amazing
full circle moment if you presented me
with your you're going in in our
conversation looking people can check it
out again on Funny or Die you asked me
one of the questions and I don't know
why this would be somehow and all
revealing or lightning towards the
ultimate goal of revealing large but I
do have a team of writers and they
answer in experience and the question
you asked me was have you ever been to a
potluck what would you bring to a
potluck
you said and I said I've never been to a
potluck which absolutely floored you I'm
sure I wasn't the only one and and I
eventually thought because Mike Dell 2fo
we had just done this on our show is
baked ziti that guy makes the greatest
baked CD on the planet Earth on if you
could see him around the corner right
there Mike Dell 2fo from New Jersey he
nails the beast wave Mike I should have
had a casserole for you next time it
would have been it would have been like
nice bookend moments between under Iraq
would take Notaro and those ready for
lunch
perfect timing a your live shows are
coming up as well I have a talk show at
Largo right in Los Angeles every month
where I do interview celebrities that I
know and it's called but enough about
you and on December 1st I have Dakota
Johnson from Fifty Shades of Grey
yes other movies do you know her father
is Don Johnson you do know Melanie
Griffith that's her mother got you your
honor she her boyfriend Chris Martin
from Coldplay yeah hired me to surprise
Dakota for her 30th birthday so that's
how I know them and so she's coming on
my talk show as a guest live at Largo
December 1st come on down rich well
Chris Martin be there to come
tig I mean for somebody who supposedly
is under a rock you know a whole bunch
of you know Dakota
I just didn't know Rich Eisen I
apologize Zach Galifianakis come in and
Sarah Paulson who is a fantastic she is
so very phenomenal
yeah that's Largo I think Zach's already
sold out so come see Dakota or Sarah
okay and go to TIG nation.com for
tickets or follow TIG Notaro on twitter
at TIG Notaro or at the real fluff
Notaro on instagram yeah or just TIG
Notaro com there you go - okay very good
to see you thank you for coming to see
rich let's do this again so I can't come
back on your show you can come back come
on my Largo show but enough about you
but enough about ya you've graduated
that's fantastic
I take mataró on Twitter under a rock
would take Notaro ma you can check out
the latest episode with me as the guest
streaming now on front of your tie
thanks for coming on thanks for his
Happy Thanksgiving to you and yours but
okay thanks God we're about eggs Edie
that's right baked ziti and Turkey no
Turkey we come back for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app